everybody what and I would you know I
was ripping his face and just letting
him have it I mean bruises
everywhere and when we got in the back I
looked at him he looked at
me it was
beautiful it's
art if I made you believe brother then I
did my
job I'm Bob at home but in the ring I'm
Supernatural is that right yes how long
you've been Supernatural instead of Bob
I guess it's only when you wrestle right
only when I wrestle a lot of people ask
me hey is he they ask my siblings hey is
he the same way he is in the ring as he
is at home of course I I don't take the
gimmick
home in the ring you're you're a
character right I'm I'm a heel or in in
in in lutra terms I'm a rudo a bad guy
rudo so I'm the guy guy that everyone
boo so my Applause are the booze mhm so
if I'm getting booed or people are
trying to puncture my tires outside or
throw [__] at me that I'm doing my job
you're doing a good job yes what is it
about like professional wrestling and uh
Lucha Libre which is the Mexican form of
it that you know people say it's
fake I
believe that's a good question I've been
doing my research when people say fake I
think a lot of marriages are based on
agendas I think the marriages are fake I
think sometimes when boxing you're
trying to bring in a new kid and a lot
of people love him and his merchandise
is selling and I had a lot of people ask
me who do you think's going to win the
fight and I go well that guy's on his
way out this guy's on his way in so it's
politics I think the new kid's going to
win so if the new kid's going to win
that tells me it's fake it's set up you
know it's in general I I noticed when
guys lose their fortunes uh the women
says you know someone for some reason I
don't love you anymore of course you
don't love them anymore because that
wasn't the you had an agenda so when we
talk about wrestling saying is it fake
the miles are real the money's real the
bumps are real what you guys go through
in the ring is amazing
365 days 24/7 I mean you're conditioning
yourself you're getting up there you're
always trying to look the part and
you're always trying to look condition
of
course when new blood comes in when I
came in I used to go up to the old guys
and said hey how am I doing you know I
always went up to them and as a father
figure how am I doing and well you're
doing okay and little did I realize I
must ask that question over and over how
am I doing you're doing and I got the
same response and I said man what am I
doing wrong so then I took a step back
and I said wait a minute I didn't
realize that I'm going to take his place
one
day and I'm new I'm the new
dog so and Alpha is not going to tell
the pup hey you're coming up the Alpha's
always going to
tell so that's when I stop asking how
I'm doing and I started hearing it from
the
fans so anytime I'm up there and they're
popping you know they're just grabbing
on of me I'm letting them in and I walk
out and I always hear they used to call
me the show guy hey you did to show up
there but you didn't do [__] and I go I
thought the name of the game was to get
over because you're doing all these
flips and [__] and they're quiet I don't
hear anything I mean I'm in the back
warming up and I'm getting ready is
there a match going on but as soon as I
get out there they just start going
crazy and then they gave me a nickname
and I don't like the nickname but hey
it's going to get me over what's the
nickname the nickname is an artist in
Mexico her name is
Bakita you know she's a short woman her
hair is blonde and she's always scorn
and all her songs are about how men did
her wrong so as soon as I come out
instead of playing my music they play
her song and then they instead of
calling me natural they start calling
meita what the they're like what is it
goes cuz your hair's blonde bro and and
you have that Stu I go man what a what a
way to go
however I was every where I went it was
sticking and everywhere I went they were
popping so if I did a move on a guy and
and and I was doing really well and I
looked for approval instead of them
rooting for me the DJ guy would play the
music and it was like more insult than
anything like playing her song and then
making me feel like I'm not a woman and
I'm not the scorn woman and and then I
don't look like her she don't look like
me but it was getting over so one thing
thing I learned about this business is
it's not about what you know also but
it's about you getting over you know you
don't have to do a lot but if you have
the Charisma and you have that Persona
when you enter a room or you do a meet
and greet you're do an autographs oh man
wow natur TR I saw you on TV and I see
you man you even look better you know
than I see you on TV I go yeah they gain
about 15 pounds on TV doggy you know but
yeah they they get excited then I had
the High Flyers next to me me about 15
50 lb 160 lb and they would ask me are
they wrestlers oh yeah of course they
are they're on this side but they don't
look the part so I always tell my
students hey man hit the gym bro you
know this is a circus in Circus you have
to look above and
beyond you can't look like that you know
like a backup cook at at at at
McDonald's or anything you can't look
like that you have to have that look
look where wow this guy could really
[__] dismember
me so when I started and I ran into Gil
Gil's garage when I got there and they
told me they do Luke JRA there you know
he's the the veteran the head honcho
there you know I said I was telling you
earlier that when I was around 7 years
old they had wrestling in wer Boulevard
and my mom took me there little did I
know that was the same guy was going to
run in years later so when I arrived to
gills and I said hey uh um I'm an
Enthusiast I want to I want to learn how
to do Lucha he looked me up and down he
says maybe you'll last a
week I go why why would you say N I have
wedow come in here all the time thinking
there going to be something and then
they [__] quit I said okay so as soon
as I got
there he put me through the
test I'm not going to lie to you it was
murder he says if you can't feel it just
powder out of course he also has a rule
if you want water if and you get water
you can't come back into the ring that's
just the way it is and I go well I have
to hydrate he goes maybe that's how it
works out there but that's not how it
works in here so it took me over six to
seven months to master his whole
training session to two hours straight
because it was it was
intense and I'm this big dude with these
little guys and they they have energy
for days so I was getting discouraged
I'm going man you know what do I need to
do of course I'm a baby in the business
as I matured I started to realize you
don't have to do them you just got to do
you so as a as a baser or a heel I don't
know if you notice when you watch
there's guys that catch them mhm well
that would be me so I said okay now I
have a purpose so when I would train
with the cruiserweights I said hey just
jump from and I'll catch you okay go
this way and I'll flip you all right now
I found my purpose now my regimen I'm
still doing what they're doing but now
I'm
different I'm almost they're uh
got garden angel cuz when they
fly you know this business you got to
catch he don't eat and I don't eat
you're going hit the concrete if you
don't yes so I got to make sure he's
okay and I'm okay so we can continue to
do the next show over now usually I
would not tell you this but since so
since we have social media
that the rule is you're not supposed to
talk about this they're talking about it
every day now you know they got a bad
guy and a good guy having dinner
together feeding each other food come on
that it was never heard of back in the
day back in the day you would go in one
side of the building and I have to go
the other side of the building back in
the day you'd be on the phone and we
would talk about it we could not be seen
together now today they're they're
driving together to the
show so you know the Mystique is gone
and I and I hate that you know my mom
still thinks it's real she go why did
you let that son of a [__] the audience
still thinks it's real my mother still
thinks it's real I never broke C with
her when I would come back all bleedy
and you know she would see me the next
day with what who where didn't you press
charges and where's that guy at now he
went back to his country and
look you can't even get him to be
incarcerated for assault and battery I
said perfect it's
perfect um there was a time that I'm
pretty sure you're familiar with the
Guerreros uh Eddie Guerrero yes Trav
Guerrero I used to photograph Lucha
libbre years ago well I think it was
Chavo Guerrero
senior I wrestled
him and my mom loves
him so I said Hey Brother think I can
get a picture he goes oh no problem so
he comes out he thinks we're I'm going
to take a picture with him right no no
no no
mom so she was excited boom and I go and
who you rooting for tonight she was I'm
sorry son but I'm going to stay neutral
on this one I go wow not even your own
flesh and blood are you going to root
for me I said it's okay again I know
it's work she still thinks it's
real it was funny right after I wrestled
him I would think I would say probably
four months later he passed away so I
had the pleasure how'd you get started
in this uh again watching my my cousin
rest Waters I just watching him I mean
they didn't have a ring like they would
be training on carpet so I'm sitting
there watching them I go okay what's the
pop I mean when are you going to
actually wrestle in the ring and the
only time they wrestled in the ring is
when they did a show so I was kind of
curious what about the ropes cuz you
guys have no
ropes and he just said sometimes we
could use the ring when it's available
or sometimes they don't even have that
facilities that what we have so it's a
privilege to have a ring which a train
in a ring cuz a lot of a lot of places
where uh say in Mexico they don't have
that privilege so when I'm training with
guys here I always said hey don't take
advant don't take it for granted always
understand that there's people out there
that are training in boxing rings that
are are just trying to I mean they're
putting ropes together and they're
fabricating their own ring just to learn
this art
Lucha Le it to me is an art I think
that's what you like that's what I like
I think a lot of people like it American
wrestling I believe is more show more
drama storyline you know if you don't
like wrestling you're going to follow
the story if the story's good enough I
just like the whole subculture of the
costumes and all that I don't care about
the wrestling there you go beautiful I
like that you said that because a lot of
people will go because their kids love
it so of course let's take them and when
you're there at least least you see the
pageantry you see the art form or you
see you know it just it just catches you
and as a photographer going man this is
going to be great on camera so it has to
have that and when I train students they
like to come a lot of guys like to train
in in tennis shoes and and
shorts I make it mandatory that they
come in tights and Boots wrestling boots
because you have to become accustomed to
what you're going to start wrestling in
you play golf you don't play golf in Air
Jordans do you you play golf in golfing
shoes and I try to tell them that you
know like it's for what you're doing
it's going to
compliment and they always ask me why
and I always say well the day I the day
you put your boots on and go up there
you're not going to be comfortable cuz
you never wrestled in Boots so let's
start from the get soon as you come in
put that gear on and understand the
etiquette that we're doing here so my
class as is right
now it's mandatory that they wear the
gear the full full-blown in or they
you're not
Mexican I'm half Mexican you're half
Mexican and half Irish but you're
operating in a Very Mexican subculture
there I'm operating in yes I would say
that when I got in there and I'd sit
down and I'm glad you brought that up
I'd be considered a uh a half breed yeah
a mut would you say that
well you're we half and half your a mut
so you're not a full full compared to
all the other guys you're you're
fighting against you're you're white
basically compared to them I'm too white
for L Chala and I'm too Mexican for the
American so I was in between the rock
and a hard place and I remember when I
came in one day and you know I'm a
[__] big dude I know you don't need
to tell me you know I know what I am and
but I try to keep myself humble cuz I
know sometimes people get the wrong
impression I'm not trying to dismember
any anybody I'm trying to get popularity
and get a good following so when I walk
in I make sure I shake everyone's hand
and I say how are you and try to you
know cordial whatever and sit down and
put my boots on but I used to have a lot
of guys you know go tell me Hey sir you
know they would try to talk to me in
English if you want a dress there's
there's a dress room over there and I go
where's the dress room and he goes oh
it's in the ladies
room and it's in the ladi's room and he
goes yeah
so you know I'm trying to digest what he
said and then I got
it I said all right I'm not one of you
I'm one of me little did he know that we
were going to lock up that
night and then I'm glad you brought this
up a lot of them want to see what you're
made out of you know okay he's Jack but
they he no well the day we went up there
and I don't want to mention
names but he got educated that
you know just because I'm being cool and
I'm being humble I'm not a doormat and I
I educated him that
night and they got educated in the back
too I was also a roadie driving the
wrestlers I used to drive them for three
hours up north not getting booked they
told me to bring my stuff because it
says they always tell me a plumber
always brings his tools you're based in
La I'm based in La I got called a lot of
the wrestlers will come from Mexico to
wrestle Mexico uh even uh we had some
special guest Ultimate Dragon uh I
believe uh some of these guys are
padas
yes thank you cuz I photograft most of
the big ones yeah a lot of them won't
drive with you like if we're driving
together to go to a to go to a show to
get a van and everyone's drive he wants
to drive individually if we get a room
he wants to be located in a different
Hotel
it's crazy brother it's crazy and when I
went up north and I was doing the roie
thing I I would sit there and they said
you know you're not going to work I said
yeah I'm just am earning my my stripes
so to speak so I'm sitting there and the
guy goes hey I might need you tonight I
well we yeah but what what match go Main
Event don't [__] this up I wow what the
pressure I said like who am I
wrestling and nobody wanted to wrestle
this guy in the back they said he's a
little bit off well most of the
wrestlers are and they pointed out to
him go I'm going to wrestle him and the
guys would look at me goes yeah you're
going to wrestle this
guy so I went over to a couple of my
comrades the ones I drive I said what's
the deal I go oh he likes to [__] lay
it in and he doesn't pull no
punches so just that heads up I I told
you that all right cool so we go in the
ring weers start beating the [__] out of
each other this is full contact
right boom boom boom and he says he
tells me
yaka and he's telling me let's take this
[__] home I said all right so boom pops
me up slams me goes to the top I mean he
comes down
full-blown grabs me grabs me by my
throat and he says don't [__] move
one two three boom I well I do my job
everyone's happy the crowd's popping
they want me to come
back now here's the problem remember
he's a bully back
there he goes I love it so much I'm
going to make you guys the new tag
team they're going now I got to deal
with natural and this [__] guy so
yeah they I mean when it came time to
lock up
and
uh very popular wrestlers got educated
cuz I would feed off of what he was
giving me you know give it to them boom
boom see you know yeah like a teacher
yes teacher what what more would you
like me to do throw him into the chairs
all right good rip his [__] mask okay
just tell me you guys do crazy stuff oh
we were just we were the you're hitting
each other with with the folding chairs
you're you're throwing each other off
the off the ring oh I I remember blood
was squirting right out of my head and
my my cing almost threw up cuz it was
just shooting like a
funnel and I just told her you know it's
all work don't worry everything's would
be
okay um we did that I started getting
that recognition where hey you know I'm
I'm I'm I'm a solid wrestler I catch
people and and by the way you know if
you want to go strong style you can go
strong style so keep cool with this guy
so with that being said I got popular I
even got
adopted uh from uh a tag
team and I don't know if they I don't
know if I can use their name
in your interview sure uh and I don't
know if they're going to complain about
that too because they're all about they
do a lot of commercials and stuff
so
um I was taging as a third as a third
member with uh Los
chos and you know we're all dressed in
gold and I was the third one and I was
like the guy that sets them up and then
pops and come down off the top so
boom just like the anchor yeah
boom so they would they would do all the
flying why I do all the sitting up like
I knew my my thing so kind of like when
you're married to someone kind of
marriage meaning if you're grabbing the
camera I'm grabbing the easel you know
you don't need to tell me anymore cuz I
know where we're at so I started picking
up from what what we needed to do so as
soon as I see my boy go up to the top
boom I'm already setting him up
you don't have to come and tell me come
on come on no
boom then roll his ass out set this guy
up spear boom he comes off with a knee
Boom Like Clockwork just a fine oil
machine and he go man you got it you got
it I go hey man I love this [__] I have
to get it and that's when I started to
realize what separated me from this
these people and these people don't get
me wrong you can wear a nice costume you
can look at the part doing a lot of moon
Sals but if you don't have Charisma if
you can't talk if you can't get the
crowd going sometimes I don't know if
you notice uh singers when they're
performing in front of people they sing
to
themselves and then the educated ones
they involve the fans they'll take the
mic and they'll say they let them finish
the verse and now he let that whole base
come in and be part of that
and a lot of these
wrestlers I see too many uh sequences
that I could call in my sleep I said
change it up a little see that little
that woman there I go yeah let her in
see that man there let him
in you know I would get in the ring I
would see a couple right in front of
me and I would tell that I go you know
she was fake blonde of course I said hey
blondie tonight this one's dedicated to
you cuz that that loser right next to
you he don't do [__] for you she goes
you know you know I go yes I know and I
got her and everywhere I
went I'd find her ass right there in
front going I'm here for you I I told
these guys you got to bring them in It's
Entertainment well they want to come in
let them in at the end of the day it's
entertainment though at the end of the
day you have to understand the
difference
between uh the guy guy that's all Juiced
up in the back I mean [__] they're
Juiced up and they're coming in
full-blown I remember I had one of my my
students with
me gavand Theo and I come on in dude and
big dudes coming in from mexic 6 62 63
Juiced and I told him hey bro I know you
like to go strong he go yeah I like to
he goes yeah I like to go but whatever
you want to do tonight I go okay so I
was telling boom boom we're going to do
this do that and then we're going to
take it home he goes that's
fine as I'm walking away I get all the
locals you know a guy you know what he
likes to do he's going to kill you
tonight and wow I go dude I asked them
what what's the point of doing this if
you're always going to walk in fear you
know this is why we train this is why we
condition ourselves to prepare ourselves
for anything and
anything so we went up there it was his
first debut in the states
he loved it we I mean I think half the
people when I was done they asked me did
you guys go at it in the back cuz that's
how believable it was that's how
convincing it was it was so convincing
that my wife says I never want to see
when you guys go at it again you know
cuz we're going out of tooth and nail
you know I acted like he [__] he
murdered one of my family members and
everybody what and I would you know I
was ripping his face and just letting
him have it I mean bruises everything
everywhere and when we got in the back I
looked at him he looked at
me it was
beautiful it's art at the end if I made
you believe brother then I did my job
you know if you [__] your pants and you
you watched it say I don't do this [__]
that's bull [__] I did my job the
crowd really gets into it the crowd gets
into it and um you have to know your
audience I've always told the the people
that I train a comedian knows exactly
his audience so he knows what to say as
far as a joke on what area he's in so
know your area know your audience and
then you perform sometimes you're
performing in front of kids and it's a
family show so watch the F bombs watch
the chair shots it's a family show we're
trying to push maybe a school maybe a
church just keep it nice and calm but
when you're dealing with an adult show
where it's at late at night you're
serving beer oh you it's it's balls to
the
wall uh you been
hurt I've had the back of this left arm
ripped and it literally tricep hung over
the
elbow uh I thought I had to get it
surgically attached reattached but thank
God that wasn't the
case I trained like that and it mended
cuz I know guys that have torn this and
and it atrophied it where it just the
arm got smaller and smaller cuz he never
reattached the muscle there's no
circulation going there so I'm thank I
thank God I don't have that problem I
torn this
bicep from a green horn kid should have
never been jumping he put his knees up
Charlie Horse me rip still finish the
match
okay um tore two two hamstrings in my
back uh I've tored ab muscles
uh number of
concussions I used to I couldn't drive
for a while because I couldn't see cu
the the blurriness there was was cuz you
have a concussion you have multiple
concussions you shouldn't be
driving
um I continue I still train to this day
I never stopped I don't think I ever
will I think the day I do stop is the
day I'm going to get old and that's you
start you know you don't you don't get
up off the chair you don't do [__] old
are you now right now I'm pushing 53
brother you look great well I I'm it's
not easy bro and uh and I and I see
these guys in Mexico 62 still wrestling
no mosc was like [__] he he was probably
close to 70 when he I don't understand
you know but I understand he was the
best mean masus and you know and I don't
know if you know this and I admire this
guy because he was not really received
well in his own
backyard but they received them so well
in
Japan wow it's all over the world but if
I mentioned me mades were training with
other comrades I don't like that guy
whether you like them or you don't like
him you're just going to have to accept
it the guy did movies you know he he was
a big fan of
bodybuilding so when you saw him you
always just had that physique because
what I understood is he was more of a
fanatic for bodybuilding but they kept
convincing him man come on you got to
look you got to look and then he got
into it and the rest is history you know
it really paid a lot off to put his his
inspiration for wanting to get into
bodybuilding into wrestling and
everybody used to say man I don't think
he was a good wrestler but I watched a
lot of interviews and I remember he said
if I go to Africa I'm going to wrestle
the African Champion if I go to Germany
I'm going to wrestle so the German
Champion too many times and I totally
got what he said is what when say for
instance you and I are
touring okay we know each other for
years and you know what I like and I
know what you like but he says no that's
not wrestling it's when you wrestle the
unknown you never met him and it's going
to be your first time getting in the
ring so I admire me MCAS for that
because he'd be locking up for the first
time you understand stand and you don't
know this guy from you know it's it's an
estrange
individual and I I admire that because
today and the popular wrestling that you
see on TV they're traveling together
they know each other you know they're
going over there their notes you know
but me m is actually hey I don't know
what this guy's going to do and I
remember the Destroyer him and the
Destroyer used to have this Feud and he
goes I never gave him anything and he
never gave me anything and that's saying
a lot meaning they had to fight for each
move and I admire that too CU that's
authentic brother so I take my hat off
to me there's nothing bad I can say
about me because if I were to say oh
he's just this guy that got over because
the way he looked no no no no he earned
it you know and if I could pick at what
is it if I could pick at his brain I
would love it
you know just to get that that
extra you know I think you could still
be a student of the game even though
you've been doing it for a long time you
know the day you say I know it all is
the day you never learn do you have any
regrets in your
life I regret I'm not six
feet you know and then a lot of people
were telling me you're not tall enough I
go but if I get jacked enough I think
I'm good you know I'm five 7 and a
half and measure uh people always ask me
how big are I I really don't do that but
I just said I'm big enough to get
through the
door and that was another thing that I I
got a lot of push because the way I
looked I like the way you look bro and
okay cool I hope I don't let you down
you know cuz I am you know doing my
study but sometimes I think sometimes
they push me
prematurely but I just listened when
they talk when the MS told me hey get
over here hey set them up there hey get
back out of the hey get back in the ring
hey cut that guy off and I was just just
a listener so every time I go in the
back they go what about this guy you
know what about this kid natural I go
he's a good listener he's a good
listener and I go that's all we need to
know as long as I [__] listen and I
tell my kid cuz he started wrestling and
I tell my students they started
wrestling just be a good [__]
listener man you know don't don't talk
over him let him tell you how it is cuz
you'll have your moment where it's the
the uh the the roles are going to be
reversed while you're telling the kid
pay attention step out of it you know
that's what we're going to do tonight
what was your childhood
life you had your dad dad
Irish Marine fought in the Korean
War uh loved to collect
Firearms he didn't say much you know he
just had to look at you so when he was
home because he owned his own tractor so
he used to take
off from New York to Mississippi all
states You' do all state travel and
sometimes he'd be home maybe two weeks
and sometimes he'd be away a
month so when pops was
home he really didn't I guess you could
say he really didn't rais his voice he
didn't have
to
but I do know that once he said one
thing and I kept on saying well just for
instance I need to do the yart okay
can't find the rake he goes you can't
find it are you're just too lazy and I
said well I'll try again went back says
I can't find it he goes and he would
just say make it very clear he goes if I
have to get up and I find it what do you
think's going to happen after that then
of course that would correct me I would
open my eyes more and I end up finding
something so not using you know
profanity not raising his voice just
says you know what's going to happen
right and believe it or not I took that
and I used it for my kids because common
sense like I'm not going to get upset
but if I have to get up off this chair
and now you got my full attention we're
going to have
problems I said wow so then I use that
now every time I you know if somebody
gets foggy when we're doing shows and I
said hey do you want my full attention
cuz right now you only got 50% of it
well I don't know what that means that
means you need to sit down brother and
relax we still got about two
hours you know I still have to do my
regimen I have to eat my granola bar
tell some jokes over here and then start
lacing up and when I'm done then we'll
talk see I don't understand that we
could talk right now in two 2 hours
later you're going to come back to me
going so I have a question yeahhuh and
he doesn't remember anything he just
talked about that's why you got to
listen go sit down enjoy yourself enjoy
the enjoy the journey brother I always
tell everybody we're here we're having a
good time we're getting we're going to
do a show
relax uh a WWE Superstar again I not
going to mention the names he was
bugging me three times that night saying
are we going to go over it are we going
to go I go we Main
Event oh it's just that I don't want to
mess things up calm down lots of egos in
this it's just look and and I'll be
honest with you I'm not a plan a guy I'm
a plan
B let's face it if you're taking you're
traveling and you're going to go do
something you have to be ready for Plan
B am I correct you got to make sure hey
what if they don't have connections what
are you going to do now that's a good
that's a good that's good you know good
question
you have to improvise you have to adapt
you have to do
improv that's what wrestling
is I sat down one day six-man tag
they're sitting there talking over I'm
way over here they're way over there
well hey natur are you going to be part
of this I go
eh let me know when we're going up cuz
it's was about two hours finally I get
up and I walk over there go why did you
make us wake I go okay
go he tells me one story before you know
it it's five different
endings this is why I sat down they're
narcissistic you know why I try to
humble myself because I read the word of
God and that's what keeps me
humble and I think that's what makes me
a better person I'm not saying I'm
perfect but it's just common sense if so
many people are talking at one time how
can I get involved the only thing I need
to know is where I need to
be and I got it you guys do
you and that was the problem uh
confusion was not one of my fine points
was to understand what they're doing
what was the purpose of doing it but
understanding we're not going up until
two hours it's not fresh enough it's got
to be right when they're going to call
us up okay guys we got about what 5
minutes let's talk it's got to stay
fresh now we're up there come on bro we
just talked about it but if we talk
about it two hours later ah do you
remember ah I have to get in there Boom
Boom Boom 1 two three why I go just just
don't worry about it just concentrate on
the third now
talk there's been matches where I've
done 45 minute one fall 45 minutes I go
we still got two Falls you understand
that right it's because that's what I'm
talking about brother you guys are
killing me and I'm not saying I'm not
mistake free if someone comes and cuts
me off hey thank you very much if I
can't do it hey cover
bro so I understand and I think I want
to make it home I think these guys want
to make it home to their families I
think they want to do another show next
week and that's another thing about
being in wrestling you don't really want
to tell the promoter that you're injured
because then that reflects on you
getting another booking so if I have a a
bad my patella is not working well and
I'm taping it I'm not going to tell him
because I want to get booked and then
every time a new promotion comes what's
really sad is they always say well I
never really seen your work so every
time you're up there you got to prove
yourself
again and I think when you're when
you're in uh different levels like
school you don't return back to
Elementary you don't go back to high
school and when you graduate of college
you don't repeat it unless you're a
professor so why would I have to
continue to uh prove
myself that I'm a good worker my
reputation should be out there already
you should know already ask him ask this
guy Supernatural what would you say is
the most important lesson you've learned
in your
life that everything is temporary um
it's
biblical 2 Corinthians 4:19
says what is visible is temporary and
what is what is invisible is eternal so
I know this is just a blink of an eye
brother you know I I don't I don't I
don't invest my inheritance here I know
there's going to be another life that
I'm going to live and that's with the
Lord and it's going to be it's going to
be a lot more than I could ever imagine
so I don't look so much to invest here I
don't look so much to get alites here
where people are praising me and giving
me Glory because I'm I'm just a dude
just like you're just a dude you know I
always tell my son when when we would
perform you know and and and big guys
from Big promotions oh I want to take a
picture with him oh I want to talk to
that guy I go you're but you're a
wrestler I go you can't do that can't do
that he's just a man now if you're a fan
I get it but you can't go up to him and
take
pictures so that's what I've learned
that I'm just a man I try to do the best
I can if I can contribute to this
business and leave my legacy where hey
man he's doing a natural move or hey
he's moving like natural's
footwork then I did my job because now
I'm still living here so to speak
through you know through other people by
taking my style because I don't know if
you know but I do have a style yes you
do so that's what I want to leave if
anything Integrity respecting what you
do discipline and just continuing to
pass it on to the next guy I'm pretty
sure you might have someone that wants
you to Mentor them and you pass on that
knowledge
too the one thing about me m as funny as
we we brought him up I never seen a son
that was going to carry on the name
isn't that
crazy so when me goes that's it
baby wow because you see blue demon has
a son R the halisco Jr you always have
these Juniors and Sons but never once
I've had hey that's me is he passing it
on or
or he's just going to take that with
him all right Supernatural thank you so
much for sharing your story hey it's
been a pleasure thank you for having me
wish you lots of luck out there don't
get hurt thank you I appreciate that
thank
you